all right so just you know I got a new
nickname from Mia Blake it's called
quake and I'm really okay okay we get it
Gwen you and Blake Shelton are the
cutest couple in Hollywood it's
incredible to have a best friend like
that guy he's an amazing person
just in case we needed more proof that
Gwen and Blake are relationship goals
she hit up her insta story to share this
super cute video revealing the couple
name they gave themselves
it's called quake and I'm really excited
about it is like going to blink together
buck awake I didn't make that up
II made that up okay so I've got to be
honest I'm down for guack because
currently fans are calling them chiffon
II which is a hybrid of their last names
Shelton Stefani and I'm not really here
for it it sounds like a high-end fashion
label and is kind of hard to say
chef funny just me okay anyway Gwen also
shared a clip that was shot on the
studio lot where she and Blake shoot the
voice she is Hey look at that that's it
it's like a delicious ball of cotton
candy delicious
I could go I could go further into that
but it'll get discussed yeah please
don't delicious
later that night it was announced on the
show that John Legend had been named
sexiest man alive ladies and gentlemen
the man the myth the legend
[Applause]
as you might remember Blake previously
held the high honor I learned it from
Blake I learned it from Blake has this
helped you get artists on your team has
your coaching style become more sex I
mean it has done every good thing it can
do for me is like superpowers
Gwen made sure to poke a little fun at
her man while he stood next to a giant
poster of Jon's magazine cover sorry
Blake this is one of mine what's the
word protege yeah I taught him how to
put a jacket over to cover he's good I
do it all yeah they are the freakin
cutest they held hands walking around
backstage and Gwen even put the love
filter on her man
[Music]
eg recently sat down with Blake and he
dished on working with his leading lady
it's no different than if win and I were
playing you know cards or you know any
kind of game she wants to win and I want
to win that's what they pay us to do on
this show is to try to win the show so
it's harder for her she's not she's not
competitive she'll be the first to tell
you right up until it gets competitive
and then all of a sudden yes when these
two first got together I did not get it
but now I'm the unofficial president of
the guack fan club of course you can
count on et to bring you all the latest
Gwen and Blake news so make sure to keep
it locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]